hi there Steve here I hope you had a
great Christmas lots of nice presents I
know it's very cold in some parts of
North America not so cold here but
colder than usual today I want to talk
about the kiss system keep it keeping it
simple in language learning
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe before I get into the
subject a couple of comments in response
to some of the comments that I've seen
here first of all anyone that uses a
foul language their comment will be
removed
I know it's become quite acceptable to
use all kinds of words today that in my
day we wouldn't have used in polite
company but I'm a little older so I
don't go for that so if anybody uses
foul language I will remove their or
there's a good chance that I'll remove
their comment point number one point
number two there was a comment about the
you know I did some videos where I spoke
a few languages and I try to speak 4 or
5 Slavic languages kind of bundled them
all
some people were critical but you know
language learning for me is not about
perfection every one of those languages
whether it be polish or slow by Chris I
don't know very well I've had an
exposure to them have some sense of what
they are if I go to those countries I
can use them anytime I go back to
reading or speaking in those languages I
can only improve so to me it's all good
so I I don't apologize for the fact that
I'm less than perfect in many languages
I enjoy them all um that was basically
it now let's get to keeping it simple so
I am struggling with Arabic and and I
ever met and I remind myself as I'm
struggling that every time I start a new
language I struggle it seems as if
nothing is going to stick we keep
forgetting the same things I make the
same mistakes on the same Arabic letters
I the vocabulary it seems you know very
slowly am i adding to mine own word
but I've been there before so I know
from experience that I just have to put
in the time but how do you put in the
time when you don't understand what
you're listening to you have so much
trouble reading and so forth and there
my solution is to keep to do a lot of
simple things and to vary it alright so
I have my mini stories I can read
through the mini story on my iPad every
time I read through it I can you know
highlight not only a word but a phrase
when I highlight the phrase I hear it
when I then click on a word I hear the
individual word then I hear the
individual phrase sometimes I read the
word without hearing the text-to-speech
which is more difficult or I do it while
listening to the text-to-speech then I
will listen to we can control like five
seconds of the natural audio so I can
then listen to five seconds
corresponding to what I had just
listened to in text-to-speech so that's
another thing that I can do then as I
turn the page I can do the different
activities so if I set my keypad to
Arabic then I just do dictation I don't
do anything else I just do dictation and
it's a very good way to to kind of
strengthen my hold on the Chinese ask
you the Chinese on the Arabic letters
and you know I'm getting more of them
right first time around it's I'm very
encouraged every time I gather the
yellow either correct or close but most
the time I still get a red X well that's
okay so I do the dictation or because we
can change in the settings you can
change which activities you do so then
I'll eliminate dictation I'll just do
flashcards and multiple choice and then
I have my English keypad there because
sometimes I want to change the
definition you know the hint the
translation and that appears I want to
be in my English keyboards are go
through some of the same words reviewing
them again in in flashcards and
activities but without the dictation so
again it's a variety of things
and I'm not sort of concerned about how
much progress I'm making oh and the
other thing I do is I go through the
same story now and in link I can set it
so that I only see this is only true on
the on the web-based version we're going
to have it on the app but it's not there
yet now and that is that I can look at
one sentence at a time so even on my
iPad I go to the web version and then I
go through the story one sentence at a
time and I can again you know listen to
one word listen to three words and then
very often it's it's easy to sort of one
sentence that shows up sometimes quite
close to the five-second rewind that we
have on our human audio so I'll you know
work my way through the sentence and
then I listen to the human audio and
then I go to the next sentence so are
going through the story in different
ways I'm doing the same basic task
listening reading reviewing doing it in
slightly different ways so that I don't
get bored now
I also go and leave through my little
grammar book where I made aware that you
know the verbs in Arabic that there's
only two tenses and the endings change
and sometimes the suffix can change
depending on what the tense is in the
collet present or in perfect form then
the suffix can also change I'm there's a
bunch of stuff there about hollow verbs
and other stuff that I've kind of read
through but can't really relate to yet
but it's useful background so that I'm a
little more aware of what's happening
when I'm listening and reading and I
just keep doing that and I've listened
to the stories 40 times 30 times
depending on which story and
continuously or continue not to
understand most of it but I know that's
having a beneficial effect on my
pronunciation and also on my listening
comprehension because I hear the words I
just don't know what the words are but
I've not trained my brain to distinguish
to hear not always but largely what the
words are so that when I have more
vocabulary
then natural speed is not gonna be a
problem for me so all of this is just
doing kind of repetitive tasks simple
tasks trying to vary it and gradually
getting used to the language not trying
it whenever I get into these grammar
books will very often they'll have the
usual dialogue you know Mohammad arrives
from Algeria and stuff but it's just
this I find that not as easy for me as
just this kind of mindless
I wouldn't call it effortless because
there's an effort involved in reading
and listening but I'm not frustrated by
my lack of progress I mean I've said
that I'm frustrated but I I remind him
herself
you know already now I am so much more
familiar with the Arabic alphabet than I
was even two weeks ago there's so many
words now that I understand I hear the
sounds more clearly so if I can achieve
that much progress in a couple of weeks
well and then other two weeks in another
month and so forth I will only get
better so I think it's important not to
be too demanding of yourself try and
assign yourself a sort of a variety of
simple tasks that you can continue to do
that keep you engaged with the language
built around mostly listening and
reading and and believe in the process
believe in your ability and you know I
mentioned this because oh yes this was
another comment when somebody commented
that they were disappointed with my last
video because I talked about religion
and politics and that's not what they
come here for I believe it's important
to talk about politics I don't mind
talking about religion and I don't talk
about a lot on this channel but I do CLE
but it and I tweet on a number of things
and for those of you who follow my tweet
account Twitter account and one of the
things like tweeted about was this new
math a system where they discovered that
the modern approach to teaching teaching
math is too complicated
it requires kids to work in teams and to
conceptualize and everything is made to
complicate it
and if instead they reduce math to
simple repeatable tasks that kids can
actually do and get a sense of
satisfaction from then we find that no
longer are there poor math learners kids
who are poor at math and kids who are
good at math is just everybody learns
and I believe the same is true for
language learning if we can give people
simple tasks listening and reading
reviewing don't worry about what you can
achieve don't worry about what you
forget don't worry about what you you
know they say Ron dramatically just keep
exposing yourself through these
continued activities and then we can all
be good language learners and at a
certain point as we gain traction we
move on to more interesting and more
meaningful content but we still continue
exposing ourselves to the language
occasionally reviewing some explanations
that probably help us notice things in
the language so there you have it thank
you for listening and I wish you all a
Happy New Year if I don't see you before
the new year but I think I might okay
[Music]